foreign
[Music]
wasn't driving Fort Knox on wheels
see me shining baby
we're locked inside it's a trap that's a
bomb all right dorks what are we blowing
up what the Vatican wow you guys are
going to hell
the great Dom Toretto if you never would
have gotten behind that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today
and now I'm the man that's going to
break your family
Peace by peace the devil's coming
I mean I knew you would come for me well
how about we all just start shooting
each other time to end this
let's take some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here
we need weapons and cars
having cars do you like surprises I
adore them
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's over down you lose
your last ride
then you might want to buckle up
oh
foreign
[Music]